today i play the role of an expert in
urban planning no jokes aside let's talk
about the mega project to build the new
administrative capital of egypt
announced by president al-sisi at the
international economic conference held
in charmel sheikh in march
there are many opinions about it there
are those who consider it necessary to
attract foreign investors and realize a
sort of dubai 2.0 and those who instead
consider it a waste of money but let's
go step by step the first attempts to
transfer the government center to the
middle of the desert date back to the
second half of the 1970s due to the
demographic boom and the rapid growth of
the urban agglomeration president
al-sadat decided to build a new
administrative capital named after him
in 1978 precisely 59 miles northwest of
cairo actually before him a similar
thing had been done by president nasser
when with the enlargement of heliopolis
district he founded nasser which today
is a suburb but according to the initial
projects it should have represented the
new egyptian capital however sadat city
managed to grow for a short period and
also hosted some ministries including
that of housing which remained there for
eight months before returning to cairo
after the assassination of al-sadat
himself the development of the city was
totally abandoned during the era of
president mubarak as its population
barely reached 150 000 and most of the
buildings that were originally assigned
to the ministries were converted to
house the newly established manufa
university finally in 2014 the
government of president al-sisi dusted
off plans for a new capital making it
one of the priority objectives of the
development strategy named egypt 2013
and which today raises several doubts
about its sustainability the strong
interest in the project is witnessed by
the progress it has made in recent years
and many experts agree that two are the
fundamental reasons behind the revival
of this ambitious idea the first is the
need to legitimize the presidential
government in the eyes of the population
and the second is the intention to move
government institutions away from the
center of cairo theater of episodes such
as the arab spring arrest and the coup
that led to the fall of president
mohamed morsi in 2013 but let's talk
about the project after the failure of
the negotiations with kuwait saudi
arabia and united arab emirates and
after the lack of chinese support for
some differences on the financial
framework adopted the egyptian
government decided to make the first
move on its own by drawing on the
national budget through a team of
architects and designers united under
the name of urban development consortium
plus five in reality chinese companies
have never completely disappeared but
their investments for a declared amount
of 1.2 billion dollars are nothing more
than limited loans these funds in fact
can only be spent on chinese sourced
equipment including material for a new
metro system that should connect the new
capital to cairo and for what will be
the tallest tower in africa partially
assigned to the china state construction
engineering corporation while the
company in charge of construction and
management of the entire city is
administrative capital for arbonne
development whose majority share is in
the hands of the ministry of housing and
the remaining 49
in the hands of the armed forces rising
from the sands 27 miles east of cairo
towards the suez canal the new capital
is the last and largest desert city
promoted by the regime but enterprises
of this magnitude aren't unusual in
egypt and past regimes have always
considered them the panacea for all ills
as for example the great aswan dam was
seen as the final solution to the
problem of the distribution of the
waters of the nile so in our case the
new capital claims to solve the problems
of unemployment transportation and
overpopulation their promises are many
to lighten the load on the real estate
market of greater cairo to accommodate
the city's growing population to reduce
pollution and traffic congestion so the
government has presented the new capital
as a poll of attraction for
international investment and the center
of economic growth thanks to the
industrial drawings we can get an idea
of the layout of the future city an area
covering over 270 square miles 68 of
which have been developed in the first
phase until 2018 intended to accommodate
over 6 million egyptians it is divided
into several sectors that of the wedding
residential neighborhoods divided into
high medium and low density zones which
will reflect the future costs of the
housing units there with educational
services and social and health
infrastructure the business district
consisting of offices an industrial area
and a solar farm a solar park that is
expected to cover 70 percent of the
city's energy needs a complex of parks
with a serpentine shape that intends to
imitate the course of the nile river for
an extension of 9.6 square miles a large
airport then we have the government
district which will host ministries and
public offices and finally the
presidential palace for the way it is
structured it looks like an urbanized
part of the agglomeration of cairo the
so-called greater network which includes
several satellite cities and this is
derived from the fact that the mega
project will not have its own
governorate but will fall instead under
the administrative responsibility of the
governorate of cairo of this for the
modest sum of between 45 and 58 billion
dollars but is everyone in agreement on
achieving such a feat obviously not
there are different lines of thought but
let's talk about how the government
justifies such an expenditure of human
and economic resources supporters see in
such an ambitious project the birth of a
dubai of the mediterranean
perfect for attracting national and
foreign investments and tourism taking
dubai as a point of reference is not
wrong especially if we consider the
image that the emirates metropolis has
managed to offer in the last 40 years
with the tallest skyscraper in the world
enormous artificial islands and the
largest airport in the middle east and
what are the unofficial reasons al-sisi
wants to use the new capital to
strengthen his position winning over the
private business sector and gaining back
the popular support that that sustained
him during the bloody crackdown on the
muslim brotherhood movement in fact
recent events such as the devaluation of
the national currency the pound the
repression of critical voices the
increase in fuel prices and the border
clashes with sudan have left their scars
on the legitimacy of the president and
his administration instead the 2011
revolution that led to mubarak's
downfall is important in understanding
why the move of government institutions
is so imminent it was originally
scheduled for 2019 but postponed due to
the pandemic the revolution was
primarily urban and gained momentum due
to the popular mass concentrated in
cairo where networks and media allowed
civilians to organize and mobilize
quickly this resulted in a huge wave of
people emerging from the center nearby
areas historic parts and even the
wealthiest neighborhoods to gather in
symbolic places such as tahrir square
the cradle of the arabs league's hq the
center of egyptian bureaucracy mogama
the nasser era nile hilton hotel and
finally the headquarters building of
mubarak's national democratic party same
procedure was followed during the coup
that deposed president morsi in 2013.
therefore the current regime is well
aware of the iconic power of the square
and this explains the aspiration of the
authorities to abandon the old and
overpopulated cairo and move to their
happy oasis in the middle of the desert
far from the people they have to govern
and from their unpredictable movements
if the displacement of the institutions
is now confirmed can we say the same
about entire families of ordinary
citizens who will be able to live in the
new capital once completed the prices of
housing units are prohibitive think that
a two-bedroom apartment costs about
fifty thousand dollars a huge sum that
is out of reach for many in a country
where the gdp per capita is about three
thousand dollars the big risk then
unless the government takes appropriate
action is that the new capital will act
as a cage for the rich and do little to
meet the needs of poor and disadvantaged
residents this is why the new
administrative capital is already seen
by many as a colossal waste of resources
critics say that it would have been
better to spend that money on improving
living conditions in the poor parts of
the old capital or even better to reduce
regional disparities across egypt by
providing services job opportunities and
projects to improve the overall quality
of life in response to these criticisms
the authorities have stated that the
city will also include social housing
but didn't provide details on when it
will be built and made available to
those in need all of this brings to mind
the regime of hosni mubarak and his
downfall the last decade of his
government was supported by the rise of
wealthy capitalist lobbyists that helped
the economy grow but prevented the
benefits of this growth from reaching
the poorest sectors of society and
indeed one of the most prominent slogans
in the january 2011 protests that
overthrew the mubarak regime was social
justice who knows if history will repeat
itself one thing is certain al-sisi's
new fortress will make the hypothetical
uprising just a little more difficult to
accomplish well we are done for today i
hope i gave you a clear idea of what
will happen soon in this part of north
africa we will hear about it again in
the near future see you in the next
video bye